you know I keep in mind those numbers
that I throw out are for those that are
in the chest Network cafe on chest cube
so um don't don't guess numbers in in
the twitch chat that's for the the chest
network cafe chatroom okay so let's
let's go I'm gonna have I'm having white
again all right Queens gambit declined
accepted or something other something
else like e5 ah okay Knight f3
hmmm just want to be assured that I get
that pond back so this is a little bit
of a quiet approach I mean I'm not going
to I'm not focused as much on getting my
dark square bishop out but again more so
just getting my bishop working here so
mission accomplished on that black does
not have one pond on those Center
squares here and what else what else is
going on here I think I might try for a
quick Queen e2 and then rook to d1 and I
think that it's the right thing to run
with here opposite the Queen we could be
having a capture but black runs into
some nasty pins if the night ends up if
there's like a bloodbath going on here
on d4 a lot of pieces die on the d4
square then and the night takes there's
this ensuing pin I believe actually no
you know what I think if instead of
Bishop e7 if pawn takes I do this right
away because if I recapture the knight
takes and is on my Queen which is a very
important detail I don't want to even
allow the night to get here so the
Queen's
since it's on b6 sometimes it's this a6
b5 idea that would be a bit
uncomfortable for white and their bead
these prep moves or reactionary moves
such as a four to stop b5 and in in
going with this expansion is to help the
light square Bishop out so my first
thought is with the Queen on b6 what is
this guy going to do I don't have an
answer to that so and I don't know what
more to be doing besides just throwing
my knight here so okay and now my bishop
is able to see the world which is a good
thing this guy he has a play on this
diagonal
and I think I think that this is a good
idea a 3 or is it there might be like a
night a 5 2 B 3 stuff so maybe maybe
that's a let's not and say we did type
of thing yeah I don't I'm not I'm not
gonna be doing that so where's my dark
square Bishop wanna go and g5 hmm
actually seems pretty good there's are
gonna be a lot of pressure put on this
actually get out of there Queen you need
to go somewhere else I want to release
some pressure on d4 and then I might
take an additional move with my bishop
to play it to g5 I'm not quite sure or
maybe if the Queen goes to c7 or home
might be home where she should be going
because she is still accessible to
attack by either my knight or later on
with my Queen rook playing to the C file
if she's to play to c7 if she goes to a5
then I might be considering a bit more
inclined to consider 8/3 because there's
none of this Knight 8a v 2 let's say B 3
idea so like right now case in point
a3 I think is a good idea and I think
the last stream I was yeah the last
stream I was playing against who was it
somebody with the handle 11 year-old
genius that's a handle that kind of
sticks out and I think going back over
that particular game where I was the
black side I was suggesting that maybe
a3 is a good idea because in that game I
was able to pivot on b4 and get to d5
with this night so I went 8 3 b5 is
gonna be played I might as well back up
right now knowing that he's going to get
hit anyhow and I think some natural
moves like getting my last piece
involved on c1 and
well actually no you know what this
might be a good move right now right now
this could be a really really good move
actually I think it is and it might be
it might actually be a winning move can
you believe that
because it is opposite the Queen and
after an ensuing recapture on d5 with my
bishop would be doing a couple things
one hitting the knight - pinning the
knight and well there's even a third
just taking on this square with the
check and then picking off the Queen on
the home square did you catch all that
Knight takes Knight takes pawn takes
Bishop takes unprotected Knight that is
pinned potential for Bishop takes pawn
winning the Queen and as follow-up moves
like if Queen c7 in response to the
bishop being on d5 there's route to c1
and this pin is still persistent in some
form and I think I can pile up on it
somehow so I think we might be pretty
close to seeing that happen it's a bit
awkward here if the knight isn't
captured well I don't know what to
suggest for black
I think the first slip-up may have very
well been that Queen b6 move okay this
is the variation I was speaking of so
let's see what black decides on it may
be the case Queen here is best or not
interesting decision okay so how can I
take advantage of this awkward position
that black is now in I could run with
rook c1 that seems like a good start
but there will be Bishop here breaking
the pin and then and then what right
what do I do after that
hmm I might have thoughts of Knight here
followed by ninety seven after Bishop e7
let's see Knight here
there should be seven night here
actually wins material I think that's a
sneaky move sneaky move is that gonna be
TKO actually Bishop here in ninety-seven
the rook is cooked and if Queen takes
Knight dissimilar the same idea Bishop
takes pawn is available okay maybe that
is the best the best thing to be running
with I guess we're going to be having
bishop there and I'll have to be
blocking with f3 or not have to but it's
probably the the best way to go about
things so I'm going to retreat the Queen
was hitting my bishop and not just to
any square this one right here because
it's welcoming exchanges in a position
where I'm up material so the light
squares are ones that I could
I think rely upon and what's the time
situation under 50 minutes
bishop here is definitely on my mind
also a for I like a for actually you
know let's go with a for missing
anything I don't think so I'm trying to
undermine the night and another way to
view it is I'm looking to open up the a
file from my rook oftentimes you'll need
to not even let's say move your rooks in
order to activate them if you just make
accurate pawn advances then you know
that could be another way to get rolling
here so um what I do I need a flight
square I want to be cautious of this my
bishops pinned rook a to seems just
wrong so let's not do that and well this
is very awkward but I'm gonna do it
because Knight could take here with
tempo okay they're not doing that but
it's probably a time issue thing more
than anything and have a bunch of trades
okay let me just stay here and next up I
just want a flight square and guess
where flight square is right here on a
light square if everything coordinated
everything should be squeaky clean here
I should probably trade rooks I should
have played rook to d8 I could do it now
and then follow up with the check and
then upon push break at the King Queens
off what's the time situation
I should just take a nap
his palm pushes okay
okay I got some pretty nuts right there
at the end good game
let me let me back up here and let's see
how either one of us could have made
could have made improvements here let me
see
so
okay so what we do my my opponents
saying I hate to see this but um they're
saying that it was a lousy game from
them and I don't think that that's the
case so what are we what do we have here
this is always going to be something you
have to be very cautious of expending a
move giving up the center and capturing
on this square when this Bishop has not
yet moved okay but c5 is uh is is the
correct way to go about things this pond
isn't needing it needs to be challenged
c5 is the one way to strike at it it's
the the most most probable probable one
is the c5 break in comparing the two the
c5 and e5 break a five is so much more
difficult to get in this Knight is
conveniently there to watch over it
already just from one move and you know
cici five the bishop is supporting it
there could always be a queen Knight
supporting it etc but as it stands now
the bishop being here is good enough c5
is the way to go pressure okay these are
these are good developing moves I think
it's just this one slight adjustment I
just I really don't think that the Queen
knows its place just yet so don't go
with the Queen move
there's castle and there's also a six
and b5
really this guy turned out to be a bit
of a problem it became too awkward as
soon as that b5 move came in I think it
it's actually hmm I don't know maybe
it's actually a winning just
continuation with that d5 break I'm a in
a better position to take advantage of
the unprotected rook the pin Knight the
rook being opposite the Queen so Queen
b6 do without
I think castles or trying to get in a
six and b5 one thing that's interesting
here is that when you play a six I have
a question to ask of myself and that is
do I allow
black to play b5 with tempo if I don't
want that to happen a four is a move
that I'm really needing to consider but
you'll note that if I'm playing a four
guess what Square I'll never be able to
stop you from getting to be for my a
pond sometimes is just gonna want to go
one step to watch over that well a
couple things involved with a three
watch over B four and provide a a backup
square for my light square bishop so
anyhow throwing a question to me early
in other words right here or um actually
you're having to do something that
you're clean right now aren't you so
maybe maybe first you have to take and
take
let me recapture and then look into this
a six move a six b5 Bishop d7 excuse me
and then castle I think this is where
that was there was a problem right there
with the Queen b6 move and that's that's
really what led to the trouble because
the Queen's having to go back it's very
uncomfortable wherever she goes
again c c7 she's on the Anoka file not
really where a queen wants to be when
still both rooks are around and c7 and
again accessible to that night might be
five type of move so that's my that's my
suggestion right there I think it's very
difficult to get this guy working
because of the the moves that were lost
right from move to right capturing I
mean it's still playable and everything
but it's sort of like a little bit of a
concession a little bit of a loss of a
time and the Queen b6 and then going
back home is there that's a loss of time
and it's too much because I'm already in
a spot where I have everything developed
and I don't know I think this is just a
winning continuation here tonight out
Bishop d7 Isabella Knight d7 and I'm
picking up the exchange okay let me
close out